RIPPED FROM TODAY'S
INTERNET HEADLINES, IT'S
RAPID REFRESH.
THE UNITED STATES HAS A NEW
POET LAUREATE, RIGHT.
JUAN FELIPE HERRERA, AMERICA'S
FIRST LATINO POET LAUREATE
BEAT OUT ALL THE OTHER
POETS BY A
WIDE MARGIN AND SIMPLY DOMINATED
THE SWIMSUIT COMPETITION.
HERRERA, SEEN HERE IN HUMAN
FORM, WRITES POETRY THAT IS
HEARTFELT AND BEAUTIFUL AND
IMPORTANT, I ASSUME.
BUT IT'S 21st CENTURY, I
LIKE MY POETRY LIKE I LIKE
MY BREAKFAST AT DENNY'S:
SLAMMED!
>>DAD, YOU ARE THE---I HAVE EVER
MET.
THANK YOU. IF IT WASN'T FOR
YOU, I WOULDN'T BE HALF THE---I
AM TODAY.
>> JUST SAYING.
>>CHRIS: TAKE THAT, DAD.
ISN'T THAT SORT OF THE
SUBTEXT OF ALL SLAM POETRY?
>> I DIDN'T KNOW "DUCK DYNASTY"
HAD A POETRY SHOW.
(APPLAUSE)
>> CHRIS: A HUNDRED POINTS FOR
THAT.
>> SO MUCH RACISM, HARD TO
CONTAIN.
>>CHRIS: QUACK, QUACK, PHIL
ROBERTSON.
ALL RIGHT, COMEDIANS, GIVE
US A QUICK POEM FROM
AMERICAN'S SLAM POET LAUREATE
>> BLACK BODIES SWIM AT POOL
PARTY, WHITE COPS NOT
INVITED. SO MUCH JEALOUSY. NIGHT
STICK, NIGHT STICK, NIGHT STICK.
(APPLAUSE)
>>CHRIS: DUDE, THAT'S LIKE A
REAL SERIOUS SLAM POET-- THAT'S
REAL.
THAT'S REAL.
>> THAT'S WHY I'M DOING THIS.
SLAM IT.
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT, MEGAN
NEURINGER.
>> O.
M.
G.
LITERALLY CAN'T EVEN, ON
FLEEK, ON FLEEK, BLACK
BABY EMOJI.
>>CHRIS: POINTS.
>> JON DALY.
>> MEGAN, BRANDON, CHRIS AND
ME TOO. AREN'T WE A HANDSOME
CREW?
HERE WE ARE IN THE WITCHING
HOUR, YET NO ONE'S FACE IS
LOOKING SOUR.
WE'RE ALL GRINNING FROM EAR
TO EAR, THANKFUL FOR THE
MANY BLESSINGS WE'VE BEEN
GIVEN THIS YEAR.
POINTS, POINTS AND POINTS
FOR ALL.
WAS @MIDNIGHT FUN?
MOM, I HAD A BALL.
(APPLAUSE)
POINTS.
>>CHRIS: THIS IS SLAM POETRY,
NOT "PRARIE HOME COMPANION."
>> YEAH, I RHYMED, IT'S
BETTER WHEN YOU RHYME.
>> I THOUGHT AT THE END, HE WAS
GONNA GO "WAKA FLOCKA!"
>> THAT WOULD HAVE GOTTEN A
HUGE LAUGH.